this morning there are new concerns
about the johnson and johnson vaccine
after georgia temporarily shut down a
site when people there suffered adverse
reactions to their covit 19 shot
side effects and adverse reactions to
the vaccine were reported this week in
north carolina and colorado
more than one in three americans or just
over 114 million people
have received at least one coveted shot
more than
68 million people or about 20 percent of
adults in the u.s
are now fully vaccinated but infection
rates are also
on the rise as are questions about what
it might take to push past the pandemic
michael george is here with more michael
good morning dana good morning if you
look at the numbers of
fully vaccinated the u.s isn't even
one-third of the way to hurt immunity
with some estimates putting the
percentage who need to be vaccinated at
higher than 85 percent
so the country is at an important
juncture cases are on the rise but
so are the number of people being
vaccinated
children are now in the spotlight in the
coronavirus battle
pfizer wants to extend its vaccination
to those as young as 12 years old
and has asked the fda for authorization
to do that
the request comes as children are
believed to be central to the latest
increase in cases there is concern about
transmission
in youth sports both club sports as well
as sports affiliated
in schools in michigan leading the
number of cases per day this week
the governor called for a two-week pause
on children's sports
along with indoor dining lives depend on
it
michigan is unquestionably a national
hot spot right now
but in new york
coney island ceremoniously reopened you
can't feel new york city you can't
understand new york city unless you come
to coney island
and amid high profile vaccinations this
one with new jersey's governor phil
murphy
there are reports of minuscule
percentages of adverse reactions
each of the three major vaccine
producers have reported a remarkably low
0.1 percent of recipients
had side effects as schools aimed to
reopen the cdc emphasized yesterday that
its safety guidelines need to be
followed
we have not yet seen evidence of
significant transmission of covet 19
within schools when schools have fully
implemented cdc's mitigation guidance
so where we are in this fight right now
varies depending on what part of the
country you're in
with michigan withdrawing from opening
to the mayor of seattle declaring friday
we're finally getting to the other end
of the crisis michelle
michael thank you